احتفال حضره الالاف اجواء صخبه وبالونات
ملونه تبعث البهجه في نفوس الحاضرين لكن
الفرحه تحولت الى كارثه ويوم مشؤوم شهدته
ولايه اوهايو الامريكيه
في صباح يوم السابع والعشرين من سبتمبر
لعام
1986 تجمع حشد مكون من 2500 طالب ومتطوع
وقاموا بنفخ مليون ونصف المليون بالون
بغاز الهيليوم خلال حمله لجمع التبرعات
الخيريه وفي الوقت نفسه لتحطيم الرقم
القياسي العالمي لاكبر اطلاق متزامن
للبالونات والذي قادته جمعيه يونايتد
[تصفيق]
لم يخطر على بالي احد ان هذه الحمله التي
كان من المفترض ان تكون مبهجه ستتحول الى
ماساه فبعد الانتهاء من نفخ جميع
البالونات بدا العد التنازلي
مليون ونصف مليون بالون انطلقت في السماء
وضبطها القائمون على الفعاليه مع بعضها
بشبكه بلاستيكيه عملاقه لمنعها من الطيران
بعيدا من الساحه وجعلها كتله واحده تبهر
الجمهور لدرجه انها غطت ضوء الشمس
وبعد ساعات تم فك الشبكه لاطلاق تلك
الكتله الهائله من البالونات لتحلق عاليا
في السماء ويشاهدها المتفرجون المشهد كان
خلاابا لكن القرار كان كارثيا للغايه
فالجو في ذلك اليوم اصبح غائما مع رياح
قويه انه جو غير ملائم ابدا لاطلاق
بالونات في السماء
الامطار بدات بالهطول دافعه البالونات نحو
الاسفل ما جعل الساحات والشوارع تمتلئ بها
كما انها غطت بحيره ايري معرقله عمل خفر
السواحل الذين كانوا يحاولون البحث عن
رجلين انقلب بهما القارب ولسوء الحظ لم
يستطع رجال الانقاذ العثور على اي من
الرجلين نتيجه اكتظاظ البحيره بالبالونات
فيما عثر على جثتيهما لاحقا ملقاتين على
الشاطئ
توقع المنظمون بقاء البالونات المملوءه
بالهيليوم في الهواء حتى تنكمش في النهايه
وتعود الى الارض لكن تسببت الرياح
المصحوبه بالمطر في نزول البالونات بينما
لا تزال منتفخه
المصائب لم تقف هنا فالبالونات ايضا جعلت
السماء غير صافيه ما اضطر الى اغلاق مدرج
مطار بورك لاكي فرونت لمده 30 دقيقه وترتب
على ذلك عرقله حركه الطيران الجوي بشكل
كامل كما تسببت الكارثه في حوادث سير اصيب
على اثرها العشرات
جمعيه يونايتد واي حققت لقب اكبر اطلاق
البالونات في وقت واحد الا انه ظهر في
موسوعه جينيس للارقام القياسيه مره واحده
في طبعه عام
وسرعان ما صنف العرض في فئه مخاوفه تتعلق
بالسلام
جمعيه يونايتد واي انفقت نحو 500 الف
دولار لتنظيم هذا الحدث الكبير ولكنها
خساره الملايين في محاولاتها لتسويه
الدعاوى القضائيه التي رفعت ضدها